abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese
merhabalar
bu kırmızılı oldukça heyecanlı ymış şu
anda kalbimin nasıl bir attığını belki
duyabiliyorsunuz Dur
tahmin ediyorum birkaç dakika içinde
göğüs kafesini rahat bırakacaktır şimdi
salonda beni tanımayanlar olabileceği
için ilk önce kısaca kendimden
bahsederek başlamak istiyorum ben Furkan
Furkan kayabaşoğlu 43 yaşındayım
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti insanıyım bir
Cumhuriyet çocuğuyum hekimim kadın
hastalıkları Doğum ve tüp bebek uzmanı
Yım Aslında buraya gelirken birçok
kimliğin arasında hangisini ön planda
tutmam gerekiyor diye düşünmeden
edemedim İlköğretimde doktorun hekimin
doğum yaptırmak benim en sevdiğim iş çok
şanslıyım Hakkari yüksek o Ağrı'da
İstanbul SSK hastanelerinde en gözde
hastanelerinde kimlik yapma şansım oldu
binlerce bebeği annesiyle konuşturdum
aynı zamanda tüp bebek uzmanı olunca
daha bebek olmamış birkaç hücre Lig
haldeyken bile anneleriyle kavuşturduğu
bebeklerim olduk hekimlik dışında da
aynı zamanda
da bir işletmeci
bir kliniğin var kadın ve çocuk kliniği
aslında da oldukça dinamik oldukça genç
bir klinik Ben mi kilit mesaiye bir
kısmında hekimlik dışında işte böyle
mali
süreçlerde bir insan kaynakları
yönetimi satınalma gibi Aslında kimlikle
eğitimine çok ilişkisi olmayan ama kısmı
da çok sevdiğim işi yapmak zorunda
kalıyorum Bu kimliklerin yanında bir de
Eğitmen kimliğim var aslında Eğitmen
kimliğin Benim mesleğim den
kaynaklanıyor branşından kaynatmıyor
doğum sonrası fiziği ben hiç
biliyorsunuz bütün memeliler doğuruyor
İnsanoğlu Aslında baktığımızda binlerce
yıldır herhangi bir sağlık Profilinizi
dönüyor Kim desteği almadan doğru
biliyordu bu sevmesem ilk başladığımda
mesleme nasıl bir şey katabilirim daha
farklı nasıl bir şey yapabilirim diye
düşündüm de gördüm ki bizim doğuma
katkımız çok fazla olmuyordum son derece
fizyolojik süreç
insanım emirlerden farklı yapan şey ne
biliyor musunuz yeryüzünde iyi bir
memeli yok ki hamile kaldığını farkında
olan veya hamile kaldığında yakında
doğum yapacağını bilen doğum yaptığında
bir yavrusu olacağının bilincinde olan o
yavru ya annelik yapacağını önceden
bilen ve mükemmel anneci bekleyen
pişmeli bu şey yok insanoğlunun en büyük
farkı farkındalığı Bizler daha Hamile
olmadan büyük bir sorumluluk duygusuyla
Şamil süresince büyük bir kaygı
sözcüğünün sözlükte O zaman mesleğime
ben hani operasyonel Bu açıdan çok
birşey sağlayan fizyolojik bir süreçte
ama ben mesleğime kaygı yönetimi
açısından bir şeyler sağlayabilirim
9aylık süreçleri hep anne adaylarıyla
onları eğitmek açısından planladım ve Bu
iyi geldi anne adaylarına iyi hisseder
kendini uzmanların bunları klinik de tek
tek Hani eğitimi vermektense daha
kalabalık gruplar halinde de bu
eğitimleri yapabiliriz ve hafta sonları
Kampta düzenlemeye başladık Anneleri ve
babaları anne baba adaylarını hem de
bebeğin Hem doğum gününe o güne
hazırlamaya başladık tabi yüzlerce
insana ulaşır güzelce çift ulaştık bir
şekilde yüzlerce güzel ama binlerce niye
olmasın Bana kitap yazmam teklif
edildiğinde hemen balıklama atladım
çünkü bu gerçekten daha büyük kitlelere
ulaşabilmek demekte He heard on bir
hikaye kitabının adım gerçek yaşanmış
doğum hikayelerinden yine anne ve baba
olaylarını bu sürece hazırlamaya
yöneliktir kitaptı iki büyük gurur
yaşadım bu kitap sayesinde ve doğuma ve
anneyle bakış açımı felsefemi bu kez
binlerce insan olmuş durmuştum İkincisi
de İlber Ortaylı gibi rahmetli Doğan
Cüceloğlu gibi gerçekten Messenger dua
insanlarla aynı yayınevini paylaşmanın
gururunu yaşadım bunun yaşında da
Manavgat'tan başlayan
peşinden teşekkür insanlarına köy
çocuklarına köy okullarına destek veren
bir derneğin kurucusuyum ve son olarak
babayım İki tane yavrum var Biri on
yaşında büyük olan kızım veren ve Ali bu
hayatta her şeyden ve herkesten daha çok
sevdiğim bir işim var ve Aslında bunca
kimliğin arasında
kahkahası bol hüzünü çok daha az
ülkesine göre ülkemize göre biraz daha
şanslı sayılabilecek bir yuvanın da
babasıyım
bu sahnede bu heyecanlı sahnede Ne
konuşayım diye
zorlandım da aslında Ne konuşacağımı bu
bilmediğimden değil tam tersine
konuşacağım seçemedim den sıkıntı
yaşadım Bence bu ülkede özgürlük uzun
konuşulmadı kadın erkek eşitliği ve
mutlaka konuşulması gereken konulardan
biri veya bir bebeğin dünyaya gelmesiyle
değişen aile dizimi de bence üstüne
konuşması gereken bir konu diye
düşünüyorum veya mesleğim gereği doğumda
konuşabilirim Aslında doğum hı zaten
kadınlar için çok kutsal olduğunu
biliyoruz Amin erkekler için böyle
erkekler aylar geçen bir hazırlığına
arkasından kadının saatten süren bir
emeğin de yılında eşlik ediyor sonra
hayattaki en sevdiği hayat arkadaşına
doğum masasında birine emanet ediyor
ve dakikalar geçtikçe O ana
yaklaşıyorsunuz ve o anda yeni bir canlı
doğuyor ve o canlının kalp atışları
hayatı boyunca hiç durmasın diye dua
eden bir baba başında ve hocam da
birinin ellerinde Yılmaz heyecanlı
inanılmaz kaygılı kahkahası da olan
korkusu da olan çok başka bir an ama ben
doğudaki bu etmedim Ben bugün Aslında
hepsinden öncesine söz vermeye her şeyin
başına döndüm benim katıldığım böyle
kariyer toplantılarında daha çok Tıp
öğrencileri olan söyle şeyler diye
sorarlar başarı ile ilgili ne
düşünüyorsunuz başarı için ne
yapabiliriz kariyeriniz nasıl edelim çok
basit takıda sıradan gelen bir deyim
Aslında Söz vermek
gönderilmiş olur herkese önce kendinize
sonra ailenize sevdiklerinize ve
çevremizdeki herkese sözler 11 O
benim ilkokul yıllarından
öyle siyah öldük lerle beyaz yakaladın
birleştiği yıllarda Ben İlkokulu devlet
okullarında okudu biz bu da sevgili
ilkokul öğretmenim Kemal örgel
inanılmaz bir öğretmenim var dedim hala
buluştuğumuz görüştüğümüz İlkokulu
arkadaşlarımızın hepsini Dur Kemal
Öğretmen bir çocuğa Bırakın bu çocuğu
bir adama bir hekime bir babaya yıllar
sonrasında bir katkı sağlayabilen bir
öğretmendir dur her öğretmen gibi Kemal
Öğretmen bize görevler verir ödevler
verdi Ben sana söz verdim elimden
gelenin en iyisini yapacağım diye söz
verdim çalışkan bir öğrenciydim ben
böyle hani yakasını çözmeden eve gidip
de dersin çalışan öğrencilerden dir
Aslında ben ödev yapmazdım Öğretmenimi
verdiğim sözü yerine getirme çalışırdım
bu ise annem ve babam çok şükür Allah'a
yattılar bir her evlat gibi ben de
başarılı de annemle babamın gözlük
artabilir
Bilirim ki aslında yaşatacağım Hayal
kırıklıklarıyla
başarısızlıklarla belki yediğini
bağırlarına basarlar Tıpkı benim
evlatlarım yapacağım gibi
bizim Onlarda bir sözüm var Onlara sözün
onların hayatı boyunca kendi yaşamı
boyunca başlarını hiç öne eğmeyeceğim
diye söz verdim ben bu sözü Aslında
onlar vermiştim ama sonrasında fark
ettim ki aslında onların bugün başına
gelecek bir hareket yapmam geleceksiniz
Evlatlarım da Başın öne eğilmesin
Aslında bu sadece onlar için değildi iki
nesildik bir sözdü bu
burada bir kız çocuğu görüyorsunuz
yaklaşık 14-15 yaşlarında İlk
tanıştığımızda ki hadi bu ben bu kız
ucunu gördüğüm an çok sevdim Bana bir
enerji verdi ve ben o enerji çok
Vuruldum ve bu kez sözü kendime verdi bu
küçük kız çocuğuyla beraber büyüyeceği
mi beraber büyürken gelişirken doğal
olarak da değişirken sabret ve
birbirimize büyük olmayacağımızı
birbirimize dayanamayacağım da aslında
taptaze birbirimize dayanmadan kendi
ayaklarımızın üstünde ama yan yana
yaşayacağımıza söz verdim
Şimdi bu kız çocuğu küçük kız çocuğu Bu
salonda
göremiyorum ama biliyorum ki Heyecanlı
bir gözle beni izliyordur O benim karım
Hayat arkadaşım Biz tabi onda söz verdik
diye evlenmedik biz onunla söz
verdiğimiz için değil söz verdiğimiz
gibi yaşlandığımız için yaşadığımız için
evlendik ben halimden memnunum
bilmiyorum O da burada sonunda O da
mutlu olur diye düşünüyorum
Bu bu fotoğraf Başkale Van Başkale
çekilmiş bir fotoğraf mecburi hizmet
yılları Yüksekova'da çalışıyorum Hafta
sonu için İstanbul'a gidiyorum
talihsizlik kaza geçirdik araçta üç
kişilik Ben arkada oturuyorum Çok şükür
ki üçümüze Yaralı çıktık
çok soğuk ekipleri kaza yerine ilk
müdahale için geldiklerinde ilk
müdahalenin ardından hastaneye götürmek
istediklerini de kabul etmedim
onlarla beraber dakikalarca bu işte önü
tamamen hasar görmüş arka tekeri bi
fırlamış gitmiş tavana buradan
gözükmüyor ama böyle İyice üçgen haline
gelmiş arabadan takılır atarken savunan
Bilgisayarım artık
bilsem çok kıymetlidir benim için
aslında Kıymet olan bilgisayar değildi
içinde kiydi Çünkü benim meslek
Hayatımda çok değerli yeri olan geldiğim
mutlaka geleceğim Notu da her zaman
verdiği emeği hiçbir zaman
unutamayacağım bir hocam da bir kitap
hazırlığımız vardı bir tatlı hazırladık
ve bende Hocama söz verdiğim sürede
kitabın tüm düzenlemesi yapmıştım baskı
için İstanbul'a gidiyorum ve o kitabın
tek tek örneği Bilgisayarım içindeydi ve
tabi kazada sarılmış bilgisayar bazen
sözler veriyorsunuz bu tutmak için size
bağlı olmayabiliyor içinde Kaderde var o
gün kadar yüzme gülmüştü o bilgisayarı
bulduk ve bunca kazaya rağmen bilgisayar
çalışır haldeydi ve o kitabı zamanda
basa Bildik
Ben meslek hayatım boyunca da sözler
verdim
beraber bu süreci Takip ettiğiniz 9 ayı
Takip ettiğiniz her anne adayına söz
verdin onların doğum yaptığı günü
onların hayatının en güzel günü yapmak
için söz verdim Bazen çok yorgundum
bazen hastaydım Ama onların o en güzel
günü hiç göremedim Fırat'ın
gölgelendirmeyi elimden geleni hep en
iyisini yapmaya çalıştım
ettik bu tabi her zaman en güzel gün
olmayabiliyor bazen zorluklarla
karşılaşıyorsunuz ve öyleki zorluklarla
karşılaştığımız da ben anne adaylarının
değil onların beni teselli ettiğini
gördüm benimki onun için verdiğim Emine
onlar fark edebiliyorlardı
Ben çalışma Arkadaşlarım bunlar benim
söylediğim gibi değişiklikleriniz
dinleyip fikriniz kıyafet bu kısımlar
2022 yılbaşı yemeği
aralarında öyle dostlarım var ki
ilkokuldan beri
İlkokulu beraber okuduk Ortaokulda
lisede sıra arkadaşlar yaptık
üniversiteyi beraber kazandık ev
arkadaşlığı yaptık peşinden kız sağlık
eğitiminde beraber yaptık tam 35 yıllık
dostluk Sadece o değil ama 25 yıllık 20
yıllık dostlarım var benim hayatım bana
bir şekilde doğru insanlara söz vermeyi
nasip etti
biz çalıştığımız yerde zaten klinik
olarak adlandırılmış yani Bizim
çalıştığımız yer bizim Yuvamız işte
yıllar geçti biz beraber dostluk
yapabildik dost alabildik beraber
İŞKUR'a Bildik
aileler kurduk ve dün baktığımızda hiç
bir kağıda yazılmış sözleşmeliyim bizi
bir arada tutan Aslında kalben verilmiş
söz verdi ve Bu sözlerin yerine
getirmesi için uğraştı emekte
tabi böyle bakınca
tutamadım sözler doldurayım Bu sözü
yerine getiremedim Emek versem de
istediğim gibi olmadı
ama şunu gördüm ki hayatta bir şey
başarılıysa mbir kazanımı olduysa hep
söz verdiğim ve bu sözü için emek
verdiğim sürece bunları elde edebildim
bazen işte
Verdiğin Sözler size değerler
kazandırabilir prensesler kazandırabilir
your bazen Verdiğin Sözler hayatınızda
çok değerli insanlar katıyorsun
mesleğinizde Karadeniz ilgili çok önemli
şeyler kata biliyor benim ücretsiz tüm
bunların yanında farklı sözlerde vermeye
başladım ben
öyle ruhumu iyi gelen sözler vermek
istedim ve sözlerden niye böyle başladı
Aslında sözler Derneği Manavgat'taki
yangınlarla başladı
biz eşimle beraber işte Geçen yaz sadece
ormanların yanmadığı bizimde hepimizin
de diğerlerinin yandığı Manavgat
sürecinde oraya gitmek istedik Oradaki
insanlara destek olmak istedik o
kendi çapımızda uzun vadeli destek
olabilecek birileri bulma umuduyla
Manavgat'a gittik
gittiğimiz inanılmaz bir seferlik vardı
sivil toplum örgütlerinden tutunda
devlet erkanına
inanılmaz bir yardım milletçe hepimiz
ayaklanmış tık Biz deprem çocuğuyuz Ben
99 depremi üniversite öğrencisi ama yaz
aylarında olduğu için deprem Sakarya'da
Yakalandık biz Ve o zaman da gördük
Bizim milletimiz böyle felaketlerde
inanılmaz bir yardımseverlik
gösteriyorum o zaman içinde Gündem
değişir ve insanlar uzun soluklu destek
veremez hale geliyorlar veya felaketi
yaşayan insanlarda hayatı boyunca bu
felaketin izleri ile yaşamak zorunda
kalıyorlar biz öyle değil de daha uzun
soluklu bir şeyler yapalım tepesine
Gittik ama çok da kolay bulamadık Orada
böyle destek verebileceğimiz insanları
Çünkü bırakın
sadece manavgatı Antalya'da Bosch'un
bütün Belki de Akdeniz Bölgesi'nde
yetecek kadar mesela bebek bezi yiyormuş
o Çünkü oraya sefer olmuştu günler
sonrasında Tanışabilir dik sevgili Güllü
teyze ve Ramazan amcayla da altmışlı
yaşlarında
yalnızlığı çifter Gül teyzelerimiz ancak
çocukları olmamış
hayatları boyunca uğraşmışlar çok emek
vermişler çok küçük imkânlarla yıllarını
vermişler en sonunda nasip olmadı kısmet
değilmiş deyip Konuyu kapatmak zorunda
kalmışlar bir fosil yalnız yaşıyorlar
böyle bir vadinin kenarında yaşıyorlar
yangın gece önce vadede bahçeleri yapmış
Sonra yavaş yavaş şüküre çıktığında
ağırlığı alev almış ay ağırlığı yanmaya
başlayınca Güllü teyze gidip
onlar mal diyorlar keçilerine burada onu
da söyleyeyim evlat gibiler keçileri
malların serbest bırakmış ki
kaçabilirsin ler zaten 2-3 dakika içinde
hem ağırlığı yanmış peşinden de evlerde
tamamen kül olmuş biz oraya gittiğimizde
ilk başta Güllü teyze veren O
çok çekirdekler böyle
olayı iletişime geçebilir açıkçası bir
şey ister misiniz diyoruz yok diyor bir
şey sıkıntınız var mı Yok diyor Yok dedi
iş ya bir iş İhtiyacım yok diyor ama
olanda bir şey yok hiçbir şey kalmamıştı
sonra Birkaç günlük Yemekten sonra
açılar günü kapılarını açtılar bize
sohbet etmeye onları dinlemeye Biz
kendimizi anlatmaya başladık bazen
kahkaha atıp bazen böyle hüzünlü şeyler
konuşurduk sonra ilk öldürdüm yapmaya
karar verdik
gerçekten birinci haftasında ürün yaptık
ve onların deyimiyle mallarını geriye
getirdik o sohbet arasında Güllü teyzeye
konuşurken ona sormuştum günü teyze En
çok bu yangında Neye üzüldün demiştim
Furkan içeri çok üzüldüm demişti
birincisi mallarımı yangın olduğunda
kapısını açtığında biraz göremeyeceğim
diye çok üzülmüştüm dedi ki İkincisi de
çizim yandı diye çözüldüğünde işte Tabii
ki izin yanan çeyizinin
bu getirmesi mümkün değildi Ama öyle
veya böyle bir haftasında mallarını
iyiden başlarına getirmiştik burada tane
ne kadar değer verdiğini almamız için
söylüyorum o bir hafta süresince yemeye
not alamayan kişiliğini Gül Teyze
konusundan konusunda o Urla'da
saklıyorlar çünkü taşıyıp kendi
bahçesinde o kapatıp öyle geri
gönderiyordu
hala her ihtiyaçların peşindeyiz hayat
boyu onlarla beraber olmaya onlara
destek vermeye Söz verdik sadece onlarla
da tanışmadık Osman kardeş Osman
karşında bambaşka bir hikayesi var
yangında biz onunla tanıştığımızda kumu
tamamen yanmıştı dört tane çocuğu var
çok şükür çocuklarını kurtarmışım
hayvanların kurtarılmıştı ve biz
gittiğimizde kulakları yanlış buzağılar
vardı düşünün ki alevleri ne kadar yakın
insanlar biz böyle gazetelerde işte
haberlerde seyrediyoruz ama alevis
ediyorlar ya kulakları yanacak kadar
içinde yaşıyorlar aynı şekilde Osman
kardeşinde hayat boyu yanında olmaya söz
verdik döndük İstanbul de böyle bir
dönemdeki ülkemizin
felaketleri bitmiyor hatırlarsanız hemen
hemen aynı içinde bu kız Kastamonu'da o
bozkurt'ta büyük bir sel felaketi
yaşadık
kötü haberler kötü görüntüler geliyordu
çok küçük bir gazete küpürü Şimdi benim
böyle yüreğimize saplandı bir aile Bir
Baba Bir Anne 8 yaşındaki kızı sularda
sürüklenmiştir ve geriye sadece iki
buçuk yaşında Elif kalmıştı
biz aynı gün Elif ulaşabildik
yakınları akrabaları sahiplenmiş Tea
akrabaları İstanbul işi yaptığı için
Elif İstanbul'a gelmişti Elif'in hem
sağlığı açısından hem psikolojisi
açısından gerekli destekleri vermeye
başladık burada Elif'in tabi yüzümü
göstermek istemedim Elif bizim için çok
Muharrem
ve bu süreç Aslında böyle başladı Bizim
kendi kişisel
ruhunuza iyi gelecek sözlerle başlayan
süreç bir anda etrafımızda tanıdığımız
insanlarla
tanımadığımız insanlarla Az önce
sayesinde binlerce insanda büyük bir
dalga döndü ve insanlar bize destek
vermek bizimle beraber bir şeyler yapmak
için inanılmaz bir istek için dediler
eşinle beraber düşündük ya Ne
yapabiliriz insanlar bize güveniyor bir
şeyler yapmak istiyorlar dernekle Şirin
dedik Türkiye'de dernekleşme çok kolay
değil uzunca baktığımız aldı üç ay
boyunca dernekleşme ile ilgili süreçler
geçirilir burada mı Gittiğimiz her yerde
günden bu
insanlardan yardım toplamak ile gel
değil cook dışında bir kuruş almamaya
karar verdik ve insanlardaki söz verin
Size Söz verdik Biz insanlar söylüyor
sizin sözün çok basit bir form
hazırladık hiçbir taahhütnamesi yok
dedik ki bir gün bir proje olur da
gerçekten katılmak istersen bize ne
kadar kırılırsın nasıl katılırsın söz
verir misin dedik Türkiye haritasının
tamamından düşünün Ki sözler geldi
binlerce söz geldi mi uzman dedi ki evet
ya biz güzel şeyler yapabiliriz ile
felaket bölgelerine olmak zorunda
değiliz felaket ki bu Türkiye'nin
bölgelerine gidelim Ermenistan sınırına
girdik Kars'a
aynı zamanda Urfa'da bir olduğunu gören
şehrin bir Köyü bu köy okulları Okul
diyorum ama tek bölümü 12-13 çocuğun
okuduğu 1 2 3. 40 bir arada eğitim
aldığı tuvaletlerin aynı binada
olmadığını karşı düşün -21 eksozları
görüyor 100 metre ilerde tuvaleti var
musluk yoktu arkadaşlar insanın
gerçekten gördüğünde onuruna dokunan
fiziki koşullarda ki okulları bize
verilen sözlere güvenerek restore ettik
bakım onlarında demiyorum Bence
batı-doğu diye bir şey yok yani olması
gereken onlar da yaptık buz oldu Hem de
bir ay içinde inşa ettik Sonra dedi ki
evet çok mutlu oldum biz bundan Ama biz
sadece Badana boya yapan dizlerine
kullanmış olmak istemiyorum bizim için
olmazsa olmaz insana temas dedik ve bu
köy okullarını ziyaret etmeye karar
verdik
29 Ekimde Karası ve hemen peşinden ne
var burada Pardon artık Manavgat'a
kaldım Urfa'ya
oradaki çocuklarla konuştuk onlar
hediyeler götürdük eğitim setleri
götürdü kitaplar götürdük montları
ayakkabılar götürdük en değerlisi zaman
verdik onlara sohbet ettik tanıdık
onları fen Sefa'yı tanıdık sınıfını
yaramızı yeşil gözlü izi tanıdık
Tuncay'ı tanıdık küçük Zeynep'i tanıdık
onlarla günü geçirdik hayatlarını
dinledik onların hayallerini sorduk ve
çok ilginç sanki film gibi ama hepsi
uçak Çünkü köylerinde gördük bir şey
uçakların çizgisi uçağa binmek
istediklerini söylediler Peki Dedik size
söz bir sürü çevireceğiz kış geçti kış
geçtikten sonra onları Bu kez Ankara
getirdik kendi evlatlarımızla beraber
Ankara'da ağırladık onları Bu çocukların
uçağı bildiğin de ki heyecanlarını bu
çocukların ilk defa gördükleri
tiyatrodaki kahkahalarını anıtkabir'deki
o duygusal gözlerini mu Bu gördüğünüz
isterdim Gerçekten İki gün çok keyifli
vakit geçirdik çocuklarımıza tanışmış
oluruz zaten mektup arkadaşı yapmıştık
birde tanışma şanslar oldu İki gün
sonrasında onları yolcu ettik yolcu
ederken onlar bu kadar mutluysa biz bu
kadar mutluluk inanılmaz bir huzur aldık
ve onu gördüm Aslında Söz vermek bir
insanın hayatına Evet bir şekilde
prensipler katıyor dedik işte bir
şekilde insanlar katıyor dedik
kariyerine kapıdan sağlıyor ruhunuz iyi
geliyor Onu fark ettik ve sözler Derneği
Aslında böyle bir hikaye ile başladı
Altı ay içinde İnanılmaz organizasyonda
İnanılmaz bir Çalışkan tek iple gönüllü
çalışan bir ekiple Türkiye'nin dört bir
yanında yüzlerce insanla temas ettik
onlarca çocuğun kalbine dokunduk bu
süreç içinde
desteklediğimiz milli sporcular doldu
felaket Meclisi'ndeki Köyü insanları da
oldu
şunu gör bu vakti geldiğinde kendi
kırarken sadece söz aldım dedim ya Yani
kurulduktan sonra projeler geliştikçe O
söz veren binlerce insanın tamamı
sözlerini tuttular gerçekten Bir Tek
sözün bizim için önemli olmadığını
aslında binlerce insan için söz vermeyin
çok önemli olduğunu bu vesileyle görmüş
olduk
Dolayısıyla konuşma başına dönecek
olursam kariyer toplantısında diyordum
ya söz verin arkadaşlar
kendinize söz verin ailenizi söz verin
sevdiklerinize çevrenize söz verin
mesleğinizin söz verin bu söz vermek
size sadece hayatta bir şeyler değil
ruhunuzda birşeyler katacak Söz vermek
Aslında sözcük kelimesi ağzınızdan çıkan
cük kelimesi Daha doğrusu ekiyle beraber
sanki böyle bir önemsiz değiştiriyormuş
değersizleştirir diyormuş gibi ama
ağzınızdan çıkan her söze Değer verin
sözün cinsiyeti olmaz erkek sözü olması
veya sözüneri olunmaz sözünü verenin
Aslında karakterin indir cinsiyeti bu
söz için verilen Emek önemlidir Çok
teşekkür ediyorum edenin sosyal
[Alkış]